hello and welcome to this video opening
I am tortoise let's check again Michael
clen bug okay so Kings Indian gather age
three line this is something that I
definitely have to study more I am
headphone played it quite often and I
absolutely have not gotten the best
possible results that should have come
from the from from the opening I mean I
had many great positions while I'm
trying to say and squat yeah it didn't
score that well so I definitely have to
yeah to to learn that opening better as
it seems that it yeah it is a good
choice as people still don't know it too
well but I absolutely don't score as
many points as I should yeah this is
again such a case what is already a lot
better unless I'm blundering something
that I don't see but this is a 6a 6b
seven nights it's kind of a joke so um
gap like him like a suffering but let's
see still not that bad it gets in a
six-night I'd be 7 is really awful but
maybe it's not so we're promoting just
yet okay this f5 as a possible move
let's see to do them well that's not so
threatening so maybe I'm really
continuing on the queenside checking b5
if he goes f5 I will still take b5
yeah that's an interesting choice i was
just just about thinking about it this
could be a move that he can come up with
but f5 is really not that much of a
problem here i think going to look at
that unprotected night f5 i'm just going
to not react you at all I don't think f4
as a threat so let's continue a form hmm
it's also good night chief fire as a
move now but that doesn't just look so
dangerous okay what about a form this
was my original idea here I came but sir
let's go for it
wow I thought this is completely wrong
to be honest because he's not going to
checkmate me anymore he simply has a
completely wrong piece configuration for
air for I thought he had to keep the
tension I mean thing as his Queen side
is already falling apart and where
exactly where exactly as blacks play on
the King side okay we'll be going to see
so you had this one yeah just Knight c3
I guess now this is a easy easy and good
or simple and good let's say yeah Roxy 7
this is the thing I mean I'm already
having quite substantial ideas here Roxy
7 or just trying to win the a porn well
he hasn't any kind of play okay so we
should be 528 Quincy for something like
that hmm this is also pretty
straightforward
ok
hmm why not just with the queen is am I
wonder as king cakes really am okay
really an option and he might have
bishop the AIDS yeah but probably not
the moment he comes to be 6i have 95 and
okay I have to watch the time
g4 in 24 is a move
that's a slightly tricky you know gfy
probably just take takes Bishop takes
this night xe5 my hats on this down now
that's probably not working 95 should be
29 f 76 won't work
yeah the night on b7
okay so what is he doing yeah this is
this one I can I wonder if I can just
take g5 here probably i can look c7 done
all right it's not totally clear now
anyway I've got one minute Bishop takes
walks is seven maybe know at the end
this rook CA this is what I'm not what I
wasn't completely sure but there's no
Roxy one and I have rupee aid if he
tries to play looks it too or something
line was lines f3
mmm taking it is this mate that's a
that's unfortunate
Jim Jim it's not not exactly ideal here
maybe maybe I cannot win this one is
covering age 7 ha thats it's bad check
check
check I shall sneak attack though the
end was ultimately what it should have
been from the early middle game but yeah
I spend a bit much rich too much time
him and made it made it interesting
again here they're never should be some
kind of nothing should be happening
let's say but yeah here I wasn't sure 95
I ultimately went for it and it seems to
win according to the engine but it is
complicated I mean maybe I should have
just I didn't want to to pass that
opportunity but gather computer is just
playing they move like that I'm not
quite sure what it is doing actually 95
is threating certain I came and killing
now I mean okay this is a funny way to
put piece of Sam plus 18 yeah so that's
probably even clearer but I mean this is
a plus plus 2 something but it is tricky
this between a 6 is a bit more
convincing yeah that was of course a
tricky move as this queen bee 768 takes
okay it is completely winning it is plus
form but it was so tricky with
20-something seconds age for 26 and now
how do I actually win ok this is winning
between a seven wins but I keep a win ok
this is not winning any more because of
Quincy aid which is a clear advantage
but not a win anymore Queen a7 was
winning just protecting this ok I mean
I'm also winning just by material it's
Plus rupee six and stuff check so Queen
a seven against winning check but I had
no time whatsoever Quincy three already
are yeah okay add five seconds I was
happy to have Queenie five and he has no
defense against this actually check
check it was just lucky that I could get
the maiden in three seconds this is the
the thing with non increment blitz you
sometimes have those dramatic situations
but you know what you're going to
deliver it made in a couple of moves but
will you manage in three seconds is the
thing yeah yeah what to say I think that
that this is you know pretty pretty bad
setup night on b7 is almost always bad
oops yeah this is a very very funny
funny seller but it's still rather
rather solid yeah if all I like the idea
and FYI is just completely enter
positional you have to keep the tension
in the center there too you have to
shoot for some kind of direct counter
play and this is just giving me a
completely free hand on the queenside
okay this was the simple move the engine
gives this one it's also pretty nice
that is so crushing probably c6 is an
enormous threat computer already wants
to return material with this position is
pretty bad but ok this was simple simple
and not bad yeah and here we get get to
the position where they'd already looked
dead when I was thinking okay did I
really play it in a way that
that is most convincing but it is just a
question of how to win convincingly in
position is so bad that you should shoot
for quick wins and this is actually
completely right it's just that here
bishop's III would be the perfect move
but okay I didn't think of it I thought
about 95 like immediately and end at six
but I couldn't really make that work
well this is you know it looks kind of
kind of messed up for black but there is
no direct window I guess I bishops III
is strongly this is also not bad so i
guess it was an ok game it was just a
bit a bit too much in time pressure ok
thanks for watching